so all populations sift across the
standard deviation the whole the the old
bell curve right if you have high
performance in a population you can have
low performance you can have an average
always right
what the law of diffusion tells us is
that the first two and a half percent of
any population are your innovators is
your big idea people right
then the next uh about 13 and a half
percent of your population or early
adopters these people are very
comfortable
um spending extra money time energy
making some sort of sacrifice to be a
part of something that's bigger than
themselves that reflects who they are
then you have the majority the early
majority in the late majority a little
more cynical a little more practical you
know what's in it for me
um will I get my money back if it
doesn't work you know will I get in
trouble you know that kind of thing you
know a little more risk-averse and then
finally the last 16 you have your
laggards the only reason they do
anything is because you basically don't
have a choice anymore right what the law
of diffusion tells us is that if you
want to have mass Market success if you
want an idea to spread or be sticky
um
you have to achieve between uh 15 and 18
Market penetration and then a social
phenomenon happens called a Tipping
Point and it just goes but because most
of us want the majority we aim all of
our efforts at the majority which
actually doesn't work because the
majority will not try something new
until somebody else has tried it first
and so there's nothing that I'm doing
that's mythical or magical
right
um there's social phenomena
that I've written about other people
have written about the law of diffusion
is not my idea it's Emmett Rogers in the
1960s you know
um
um the only thing that I did like
anything that works is I had the
discipline to do it that's right you
want to get into shape you have to have
the discipline to do it you want to be
healthy you have to have the discipline
to do it and so and you have to get
comfortable that you cannot predict when
success happens you just have to believe
that the process works and you stick to
the process that's all I did and
everything that it is written about in
that book yeah that's literally the
thing that I followed